Here we go
Oh my God
*ping pong*
This is not...
How I pictured my life going.
Hi guys! My name is Grace Helbig.
If you didn't know, now you know, your life is different now.
I hate this.
I hate this so much.
This is a genre
This is a genre.
*breathy laughter*
God
&%#@
Why
Let's just commit.
I've just come back from Vidcon
the big YouTube convention
that happened in Aneheim
and I lost my voice.
This is not a shtick.
I went to France, and then I went to the convention.
And then yesterday we shot three episodes of my podcast, "Not Too Deep"
Listen to it on Soundcloud or iTunes.
or watch full episodes on Fullscreen
Oh my God
and this is the aftermath of my voice
I didn't...not want to post a video for you today.
So I decided to embrace something that I
don't enjoy directly
ASMR
I feel such anxiety doing this!
But this is all I have left!
This is really all I have left.
So we're doing a slight ASMR style stream of consciousness.
I feel crazy.
My apologies out there to those of you who also do not enjoy ASMR
And my sincerest you're welcomes to those of you that do!
Ewww...ewww...ewww
*self doubt*
Maybe I should have thought stuff to talk about before I started this.
How does Celine Dion do this?
Hopefully my voice recovers and we can regular videos going the rest of the week
But if not, this might just be a whole week dedicated to ASMR.
Oh God!
Ok, you know what? &%#@ it!
If we're going to do an ASMR video,
Let's start &%#@-ing with ASMR!
Ready? Here we go!
I have a microphone...right here
So let's ASMR the &%#@ out of this ASMR video!!
(scissor chopping sounds)
I hate it! I hate it!!
I hate this so much!
I don't want to-
No!!
(clacking sounds)
Dirty sock
(cloth rubbing)
I feel dirty! I feel dirty!!
This is a dry erase board eraser on top of a dry erase marker.
Watch this!
(rubbing sounds)
I don't like...who I've become.
This is a piece of paper.
(crinkling sounds)
Does that do anything for you guys?
I feel sweaty and also...gross.
(pen clicking)
Not so much.
(fingering hair)
Okay...okay...okay
You know, I think...this was a fun experimentation
I'm going to go rest whatever's left of my voice
And hopefully get back to regular videos this week
If you guys enjoyed this video at all
give it a thumbs up!
and subscribe to this YouTube channel
I make videos Monday, Wednesday, and Friday sometimes
If you want me to do more ASMR
leave a comment down below.
Will I actually do it?
Very likely not.
I'll see you guys...
I don't know. I don't know.
I really, truly don't know.
Oh, God!
Good luck with your quiet boners.
(laughing)
I feel so uncomfortable.
More than I normally do.